welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and now that loki revealed it was
kang
the whole time and that kang is really
the whole of time
did this time a whole kill iron man of
course not we all saw what happened tony
stark pulled the sticky bandit's
maneuver to snatch the infinity stones
from thanos's hand and the ensuing burst
of radiation
burnt him to death look whatever puts
hulk in a sling puts us in a grave
however he who remains the kang variant
was well aware of all happenings in the
mcu timeline
including thanos based on him using
thanos as a hungry hungry example in his
pop quizzes
therefore he probably also knows the guy
who killed him
and this was recently confirmed in a new
detail spotted in concept art from the
show's production designer of he who
remains
office in the citadel which showed on
his shelf iron man's helmet
this awesome visual was likely inspired
by kang's hall of trophies and his
fortress
in uncanny avengers number 8 from 2013
in which she collects trophies from
conquered versions of spider-man captain
america hulk everybody
and i believe that this kang variant not
only witnessed tony stark's death but
that he specifically
wanted it to happen needed it to happen
and orchestrated events so that it would
happen
using a partner in crime who you might
ask
well if he's the matrix architect the
father of the timeline
there must be a mother an oracle the
ancient one recently i explained how
many of the loose ends that we've seen
in the mcu
may actually be glitches or patches
within king's matrix
and i pointed to the moment that he said
i've lived
a million lifetimes i've gone through
every every scenario this is
the only way which i see is a nod to
doctor strange infinity war who looked
ahead at 14 million 605 future outcomes
and found only
one successful path forward tony
there was no other way no other way
than the path that he who remains just
took credit for paving
every step you took to get here
i paved
the road you you just walk down it
i propose that the alternate dates on
the avengers quantum computer could have
been evidence of kang
rigging the time heist to go a certain
way and that the pruned sanctum
sanctorum that we spotted in the void
could have been kang striking a deal
with the ancient one to oust her
predecessor
in exchange for her making the avengers
prune their branches from his precious
sacred timeline
real quick losing your hair can be a
bummer two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 now
there's nothing wrong with being smooth
up top like professor x or luke cage but
i know it is stressful for the guys i
know who are going through this but with
keeps it's easier and more affordable to
get treatment for your hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy though you'll never have to go
into a doctor's office with keeps you
get 24 7
access to a doctor who designs the best
plan for you they offer other helpful
tools and services including a tracking
tool so you can monitor your progress
find out why keeps has more 5 star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars you'll
notice also in this concept art is a
cauldron that looks pretty similar to
the cauldron of the cosmos on the
sanctum ground floor that doctor strange
accosted tony for getting too handsy
with are you seriously leaning on the
cauldron of the cosmos
notice that what the bro look in
tony's eyes this motherfucker's gonna
kill me
and he did why well the cauldron of the
cosmos is used by doctor strange in the
comics to ponder the mysteries of the
universe for hours
and to check for mystical threats on the
horizon this could be how
he remains found and tamed a
trans-dimensional monster like goliath
which was a crucial
key to his victory over other kang
variants to end that multiversal war
and remember we never found out how the
ancient one came into possession of the
time stone
the gem that allows reversal of time
creation of time loops etc something
that would have been
a time lord's most precious relic
something that functions similarly to
kang's technology that could have come
from the hands of kang and he only would
have allowed another to possess it for a
good reason
doctor strange told tony stark that of
all the timelines he looked at there was
only one
in which they were successful how many
we win
one and later on in endgame strange
calls back that moment by raising one
finger to tony to signal to him that
now was the time for him to make his
ultimate sacrifice play
and the reason strange was so grim when
he looked tony in the eyes and said
one was that he knew that he would be
sentencing this man to his death but
endgame also had this cryptic moment
from the ancient one
why the hell did strange give it away
what did he say strange he gave it away
he gave it to thanos
willingly yes why i have no idea maybe
he made a mistake
or i did strange is meant to be the best
of us
so he must have done it for a reason i
fear you might be right
that scene took place in 2012 about five
years before
strange would become a sorcerer and that
only happened after the ancient one
died but she couldn't foresee past the
moment of her death
just like he who remains seemed to be
unable to do
so i think this moment on the sanctum
rooftop was her realizing that her
partner and his sacred timeline are more
in danger than she realized
and so surrendering the time stone to
bruce banner despite the variant branch
that would cause
would be a necessary step in kang's
master plan but again why script out one
victory path for steven strange to
foresee
that would necessitate tony stark's
death it's because tony stark
knew too much or he was about to
when scott lang stumbled into a time
vortex in the quantum realm
something i suspect we will learn more
about when kang returns in ant-man the
was quantomania
probably via that chronopolis city in
the background there it was really tony
stark who actually decoded the mechanics
of time travel
how to navigate the timeline the
avengers were hopeless without tony
and unlike kang tony did this by himself
he remains explained how nathaniel
richards in the future discovered the
existence of alternate universes but it
seemed like he wasn't able to
do anything with that discovery until
another variant walked into his reality
and began to compare notes with him
stark didn't have a lab partner variant
of himself
just a popsicle brain freeze from his
daughter yet he achieved this eureka
moment
scientific research that nathaniel
richards in the future probably use
in order to achieve his discovery so
kang's ultimate fear
was that had tony stark continue to live
after the battle of earth he inevitably
would have built on his timeline
knowledge
and discovered kang's existence and
confronted him or
even worse destroyed his own quantum
navigation technology and
burned his research to let it die with
him so that nathaniel richards
could never build on it and become kang
and so
from a cosmic point of view the true
purpose of the ancient one handing over
the time stone
the true purpose of doctor strange's
premonition was not to defeat thanos but
to kill tony stark
before he could erase kang from
existence and folks if we can credit a
rat for saving the universe we can
credit these two for killing its front
man
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow and subscribe to
new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
you